Vanderpump Rules Posse has assembled but
the end game still unclear welcome
everyone to Entertainment Tonight
Kevin's off tonight but this y'all is
our March Madness ratings have doubled
for the Bravo hit since everything went
down and now the Scandal bubble is about
to burst
this is definitely gonna be unlike any
reunion we've ever had before
day here in Los Angeles free reunion
coffee I just got my nails done new
photos Ariana Maddox arriving to today's
reunion taping wearing sweats with the
words 1-800 boys live Tom Sandoval was
dressed in all black and on a smoke
break the Vanderpump star will no doubt
be hammered with questions about his
affair there's consequences to my
actions we're told Raquel Levis is ready
to apologize she was super chatty in a
new interview it started off as a
friendship
and it turned into something more
there's a rumor on Twitter that you guys
had a threesome no oh that's not okay
are we gonna see more you and Tom
Sandoval I
I don't know where a relationship is
going to be yeah
what Raquel have to say about what
happened I don't pay attention to any of
them the reunion shooting here in Van
Nuys California is shaping up to be a
showdown here's what we know so far
there will be Security on set and Bravos
let the cast members know this studio is
a safe space so no matter how heated
things get it is not okay to put your
hands on one another and then there's
the issue of Sheena and Raquel you'll
recall Raquel filed a restraining order
again Sheena claiming that she punched
her when she learned of the affair
Sheena has denied this
Sheena
who knows what happened that night
regardless they won't be allowed within
a hundred yards of each other Bravo
released two separate seating charts
showing how they'll pull off two
different shoes dude can you stop I
can't unseeing the bully that you were
to her for no reason Sandoval rushed to
defend Raquel in last night's episode
which was taped before news of their
cheating scandal broke Vanderpump Alum
Jax Taylor Made this startling claim has
Sandoval cheated on Ariana before yes
100 100 in the last couple years for
juice yeah
did you know I just know I just know
things
[Music]